BUT I THINK THIS IS HIM.
>> Mike: BRIT HUME THANK YOU
FOR LABORING WITH US ON
LABOR DAY, MANY THANKS.
JUST DAYS BEFORE THE 20TH
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11 ATTACKS,
PRETRIAL HEARINGS FOR THE
ACCUSED ARCHITECT FOR THE
MASSIVE TERROR PLOT ARE SET TO
BEGIN.
LUCAS TOMLINSON GUANTANAMO BAY,
CUBA, WITH THE DETAILS.
>> 20 YEARS AFTER 9/11 ATTACKS,
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A TRIAL FOR
THOSE ACCUSED OF PLANNING IT.
AFTER PROCEEDINGS PAUSED FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR DUE TO
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC COME AT THE
TRIAL SET TO RESUME WEDNESDAY.
15 YEARS AGO DOESN'T DETAINEES
ARRIVED AT GITMO WITH BLACK
SITES AROUND THE WORLD.
INCLUDING ACCUSED 9/11
MASTERMIND KHALID SHEIKH
MOHAMMED ALSO KNOWN BY INITIALS
KS HIM.
THEN PRESIDENT BUSH ANNOUNCED
ARRIVAL.
>> IT IS INVALUABLE TO AMERICAN
AND ALLIES.
OUR INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
BELIEVES THAT AL QAEDA AND
ALLIES WOULD HAVE SUCCEEDED IN
LAUNCHING ANOTHER ATTACK AGAINST
THE HOMELAND.
>> THE ATTORNEY FOR THE NEPHEW
ANOTHER GITMO DETAINEE ACCUSED
OF WEARING $120,000 FOR THE 9/11
HIJACKERS UNITED EMIRATES.
HIS CLIENT WAS TORTURED.
>> IN 15 YEARS OF DETENTION OF
GUANTANAMO TAUGHT US ANYTHING,
IT IS THAT JUSTICE FOR AMERICA
CANNOT COEXIST WITH THE
MANAGEMENT OF AMERICAN VALUES.
>> KHALID SHEIKH MOHAMMED
CHARGED WITH KILLING 3,000
PEOPLE ON 9/11.
PROSECUTORS SAY HE BOASTED ABOUT
PLANNING THE ATTACKS.
AND HE WILL BE IN GITMO WITH
OTHER VALUABLE PRISON NUMBERS
DON'T LIKE PRISONERS HE IS ONE
OF A HIGH OF 680 DURING THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION.
TODAY IT COST $13 MILLION A YEAR
TO HOUSE EACH PRISONER AND
70,000 A YEAR FOR CONVICTED
TERRORISTS INTO SUPERMASSIVE
PRISON IN COLORADO.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
UNDER PRESSURE TO CLOSE GITMO,
FOX HAS LEARNT THERE'S A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR EXPANSION TO
BUILD NEW WORK SPACES.
CONGRESSMAN MIKE WALT SAYS IT